in today's video I'll be attempting to
eat like YouTubers Wellness darling
Natasha ocean well you know kind of sort
of we'll see before we get into it
definitely check out my disclaimer on
screen and if you're not already
subscribed please get on it Natasha has
a lot of wedding day content so I'm just
gonna base this off of one of the most
recent ones that I saw at the time of
filming and of course we gotta start
with coffee this is my second coffee
from morning the first was very
functional it's got a very specific
function to it okay it's not to be
enjoyed it's got one purpose and it's
effective hey Sarah the second one is
for fun hopefully it's not functional
the misfunctional we've got a problem I
definitely feel that except my function
coffee is mainly to like help me wake
the up to safely care for my kids
and my second coffee of the day is more
for relaxation and pleasure because I
finally get to enjoy it quietly without
a bunch of people screaming my name I
have the most extremely extra a coffee
ritual I'm going to take you guys with
me today so right now this is how I'm
doing it I've got my two shots of
espresso I have some soy milk but I
don't like it all to be soy milk because
then it's like a little too sweet soy
milk is naturally sweet and it gets too
sweet um so then I do the rest of almond
milk because I don't want two coffee-ish
I like a little bit more milky and then
I add a hint of this
um french vanilla oat creamer I love
this stuff it's not sweet at all but it
just adds like a little hint of kind of
creaminess and also the vanilla flavor
and most importantly you have to have a
matching straw and while I take this
little meditative moment with my second
coffee of the day Abby is it safe to
rely on coffee to make you poop
so first of all as most people watching
can probably attest a strong coffee can
end us often make you need to poop
research suggests that this can often
occur within just four minutes of
drinking it so yeah yeah you better be
prepared part of this is related to
coffee's makeup so water caffeine other
really important bioactive compounds
which are all playing a role so coffee
releases the hormone gastrin which
contracts the colon muscles and gives
you that urge to go but the other really
interesting part is the whole routine of
it all having a strong bathroom routine
AKA a time a day at the same time a day
when you can peacefully go without
disturbance is often key for promoting
bowel motility and regularity thanks to
the strength of our brain gut access so
is it safe to rely on coffee as part of
your routine well I mean whether or not
you mean to most of us just kind of do
this naturally because we wake up and we
have coffee in the morning and I don't
think you need to stop that out of fear
that your bowel is becoming addicted we
definitely wouldn't want to rely on
caffeine solely for motility and
regularity because too much and we can
end up with diarrhea and not to focus on
things like fiber can really affect the
quality of our poops but if you need to
stop drinking coffee and therefore are
worrying that you won't be able to poop
without it maintaining that same morning
routine like we did when we had our
coffee in the mix definitely can help
all right drop the twins off the pool
it's time to fill her back up what's for
breakfast Natasha
we've also got poached eggs with carrot
hummus and like a tomato and sunflower
salad and then sourdough and then I
don't know if that just looks it looks
tasty but I don't know what it is this
is what intrigues me the most
oh sweet or savory sweet or savory
I mean that waffle looked Next Level
good but you guys are always harping on
me for doing sweet breakfast so we're
gonna go Savory today because it also
looked amazing and also just probably
way easier for a weekday okay so Natasha
had carrot hummus on that plate which
looked damn good because I love hummus
and I love carrots but why make hummus
when you have hummus and also have
carrots so we're going to put them
together and see what we got
that sounds like some kind of fun
together and it sounds like a preschool
song that
can't quite grasp it okay hummus down
this is the first time I'm using this
food processor so if it is a complete
fail we'll do a five hours later while I
redo it this is my massive bowl of
cooked carrots because as you guys can
see I eat a lot of carrots because it's
one of the easiest vegetables on my gut
and it's also one of my favorites and
the kids love them too so it's just like
a family affair carrots let's do like a
good amount and we don't need any more
salt I don't think
yes it would look better if I made it
from scratch guys what can I do to make
this better you know when you try to
save time and you just end up spending
more time fixing the problems that
wouldn't have been a problem had you
just done it right in the first place
it's basically how I spend all my day my
lemon juice a little avocado oil it's
probably good
what else do we need what else oh we
need some toast
guys
this is the best sourdough in Toronto in
my opinion what else get in there baby
this is how you poach an egg I always
order poached eggs because I love them
but I also feel like
it's annoying to make them at home
because you can only put one in it at a
time okay oh
a little bit of vinegar to a low a
little simi simi and take any kind of
instrument
get a little Vortex going try not to
Splash yourself with boiling water
you go
it's like a little dance it's an
interpretive dance
let that sit for about three minutes and
we're gonna get the rest all ready to go
this looks amazing let's recap here we
have protein in our hummus plus our eggs
I've got healthy fats in our avocado
plus lots of fiber in our sourdough and
our little salad I always forget about
breakfast salads but it's super
satisfying okay we got a poke oh yeah
look at that look at that look at that
oh yeah baby I don't know how I'm doing
this but
[Music]
and speaking of diets that slap I want
to touch on Natasha's approach to her
diet because some might call it out as
problematic
[Applause]
okay so you guys know that usually I.E
intuitively if you want to call it that
I eat when I'm hungry I stop when I'm
full that's how we do it but because I'm
trading for my first 100 mile ultra
marathon race and my training has
changed a little bit we're also Shifting
the food philosophy to Girls Gotta Eat
and that means just being extra generous
with my portion because my training
volume has gone up like before I was
training four hours a week and I was
eating probably like 2 300 to 2500
calories now I'm training six hours a
week I've got two two hour endurance
sessions two one hour gym sessions I
want to make sure that I'm prioritizing
performance and that I'm really fueled
up and that I'm recovering properly so
Girls Gotta Eat so first of all I do
appreciate the air quotes on intuitive
eating here because a lot of intuitive
eating experts would clean that her
approach is not really intuitive eating
and by definition intuitive eating is
not just eat when you're hungry stop
when you're full it's about rejecting
the diet mentality respecting your body
and its natural shape and size rather
than trying to manipulate it to lose fat
Natasha has a lot of videos on her
Channel specifically outlining how to
lose fat and honestly I think they're
great like they're evidence-based
they're helpful and they offer
sustainable nutrition first approach
even if they're not officially
compatible with intuitive eating but you
know what
is her fat loss
as we see in this particular video I
think that makes complete sense this is
just my opinion but I think intuitive
eating doesn't need to be done
officially or perfectly or in its
entirety to be beneficial and I think
that Natasha has a really great grasp on
what works for her well said and I am
not training for a marathon so I
definitely don't need 27 to 3 000
calories so even though I personally
don't share exactly how many calories I
eat or exactly how much I eat I do
assume just based on my own knowledge of
my own body that it's probably a little
less than that and this is why I don't
like those Challenge videos where people
eat exactly like another celebrity even
though it doesn't feel good to them and
speaking of copying someone else's day I
won't be doing this
oh
[Applause]
oh I hate leg day thankfully I do not
own a leg press for good reason but I
can get down for a little 20-minute OG
Natasha ocean workout let's do it
[Music]
all right I enjoyed that not a marathon
workout so probably don't need a
marathon meal but your bro can always go
for a little lunch Natasha what are we
having
[Music]
love this journey for us except I'm
gonna do a less aesthetic less time
consuming version oh
I knew this would be a bad idea because
not to diminish the work of fellow
creators but like who has time to cook a
full meal from scratch in the middle of
the work day ain't nobody got time for
that
I do not this is more than I even
normally do so yet the thought of
cooking chicken from a raw State at 12
o'clock is completely foreign to me so
I'm gonna lean on my trusty Castle
uh rotisserie chicken you have to say it
that way castle and I'm gonna make like
a solid version of this with all the
same flavors but just easier I'll show
you what I mean
we're gonna throw our salad greens down
some orange our beets our chicken
got our walnuts some Chev
lemon
oink a little honey
[Music]
salt
oh there's a lot of pepper there pepper
little Harissa and a little avocado oil
[Music]
so Natasha has two big slices of
sourdough with her lunch which totally
makes sense giving her training regimen
carbs are so important especially when
you're training for endurance but I know
my body and my needs and I think a
single slice will totally do the trick
this smells amazing the Harissa spice
mix usually I buy Harissa in a paste but
I found on the spice mix and I was like
you know I feel like this is more useful
in general I can put it into more things
and it just like
aromatics is next level good we've got
protein in our chicken fiber in our
fruits veg and all the greens plus the
sourdough bread and we got healthy fats
in the cheese olive oil and the walnuts
on top for something I Just Whipped up
on the Fly I'm pretty excited about this
we gotta get a little bit of the
beet action
[Music]
the Harissa nailed it and speaking of
carbs to meet my own needs I probably
don't personally need this
honestly I'm just gonna say it I don't
really like juice and as I talked about
in my video on what a dietitian doesn't
eat you know I used to cite juice as one
of my biggest fear Foods the thought of
drinking my calories especially like
straight up carbs was like sacrilege to
me but once I allowed myself to have
juice without judgment I don't know I
actually just realized I didn't really
like it that much I have really
sensitive teeth so the thought of having
a big glass of something super acidic
and sweet doesn't sit well with me and
also I'm very prone to energy crashes
after having a lot of naked carbs like a
glass of juice that said Natasha is
training so she needs all the naked
carbs and calories and hydration that
she can get so I think juice is an
incredible staple for those with heavy
training needs and speaking of yummy
carbs another snack is on the agenda
here
anything that's as close to salted
caramel as possible I'm there
oh my God I do am a full-on salted
caramel addict I'm obsessed with it
anything salted caramel it's for me and
I also love me a froyo Bowl so normally
I would be all in on something like this
but I ate dinner at like a geriatric
hour with my kids and I also know myself
at these Froyo places like you give me a
bowl this big I will just fill it just
to be filled with like 30 dollars worth
of toppings I want it all even if I'm
only hungry for like two bites
so I just want to be honest and
transparent here that as much as I would
love me a mid-afternoon Froyo Bowl it
probably just wouldn't work for my
general eating schedule AKA
save it for dessert
[Music]
uh that looks insanely gorgeous though
also annoyingly fussy considering that I
know my kids don't like sweet potatoes
and I would probably spend an hour
expertly and aesthetically Fanning them
out only for them to just Chuck it on
the ground so I'm going like a much more
simple easy fast version let's do it
we're gonna cook this
again the French are going to come after
me all Papillon papillons and papillot
on Papillon that's how we say in Canada
okay we have sweet potatoes going down
no need to Fan no need to do anything
fancy just make a little bed a little
bit of avocado oil salt
pepper oh
my life is ruined I'm ruined I have
nothing left except Spiderman all right
moving on fish
nice little piece of white fish here
this is going to become like the
McDonald's like salt pepper combo that
they just used for quick seasoning a
little salt and pepper let's throw some
snap peas down I've got some
artichokes a little bit of oil I'm gonna
just put some of that flavored oil there
yup and some lemon now we attempt to
wrap this up and I know I'm gonna feel
greatly at that exercise because I made
it too damn big
[Applause]
need a larger piece of parchment
nice May succeed we're going to pop this
into a 40 degree oven until the sweet
potatoes cook down and the white fish is
I love on Papillon cooking it's so easy
where are my oven mitts guys oh it's
Beauty this literally took 20 minutes
guys and yes I admit it's not as
aesthetic as the beautiful fan sweet
potato situation but it meant that I got
something else done in my day and that
I'm thankful for yeah protein in our
white fish here healthy fats in the oil
and the avocado and the pine nuts I
added oh I'm excited yeah
here yeah P actions not appetizing right
net guys I'm sorry about that
um artichoke oil is a must it does
double duty and it performs she works
she works oh it is so good it is
perfection I'm not gonna mess with it
but Natasha's Froyo adventure of putting
all the yummy toppings on definitely got
me inspired so we're gonna go in my
pantry find all the goodies we can and
put together an epic Froyo Bowl let's do
it
all right
it is a mess in here I really need to go
through and just like organize all this
crap I mean we have some great varieties
here AirHeads might be an interesting
topping
oh
Smarties other kind of Smarties Canadian
Smarties Reese's Peanut Butter Cups a
massive cookie from a bridal shower
which has not been consumed and probably
shouldn't be consumed at this point oh
gummy worms
gummy bears minion cookies oh my gosh
the variety here guys you don't know
until you go digging all the crap you've
got here and I got some coconut got some
nuts I think we'll throw some fruit in
there we got a good Bowl let's do it so
this is the problem when you go to the
Froyo place my eyes are bigger than my
stomach and I just want to sample
everything I don't even know how this
was in my pantry and now suddenly I need
it I need it all in this bowl this this
is a modest size Bowl all right Froyo
down we got to leave lots of space for
everything else allegedly I am
Legend
some berries a little a little fresh
fruit all right I'm doing some
pistachios because I love pistachios oh
coconut
always a hit
decisions oh these are really delicious
I know we have fresh blueberries
but I've got freeze-dried blueberries
and frozen blueberries
with
chocolate on them
this is too fun and then like a little
something sweet
because this is not sweet
we'll do a gummy worm
just like that what a bowl
he's posing
she's flexing
right girl oh yeah
how fun is this I don't even have to
roll on downtown spend 30 bucks on
basically just candy because I have
enough of it in my own Pantry
um
brain freeze
this is so much better than the Froyo
place anyway you know dollar or an ounce
but people don't know how much is an
ounce it's not a lot and then when you
fill that whole thing up right to the
top and the swirl and the toppings
you're looking up pretty penny for just
like let's forget it great it's my rant
raise your hand if you agree but I feel
like a lot of us women have trust issues
because of Pinkberry like exclusively
Pinkberry because they give you this
bowl
[Music]
if you're Froyo obsessed especially in
today's economy it has a way more
budget-friendly option to just go to the
dollar store pick up some little snacks
and candies get some fruit whatever
toppings you are excited about and then
you can build endless Bowl varieties at
home
mmm I'm gonna have I'm gonna have these
mandarins because they're a really good
at lunch and I'm just fancying mandarins
you guys think I'd forget about the
mandarins we go through these things
like water I also desperately need a
bedtime snack because I underestimated
how light the fish was
oh there's nothing better than like a
juicy plump
Clementine so I got a couple of these
Ella Natasha and because this is just
not gonna cut it I've also got this
deliciously addictive coconut seed nut
cluster situation they're like so good
um
okay that was such a fun day and I feel
like unlike every other diet that I've
watched or reviewed or tried to kind of
like use this inspiration for my own
meals in some ways Natasha's meals are
spot on we got color variety bounce
macros we got lots of fun Foods in there
and Natasha actually eats enough
calories to meet her needs revolutionary
unfortunately I literally didn't have to
change anything at all looked so good I
basically just tweaked the meals and
portions to meet my own dietary needs
and also made them a little simpler and
easier because I just don't have the
patience to cook like that all day but
if you guys like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on Whose diet you'd like me to try
next subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]